look at this [ __ ] bubble boy [ __ ]
trump one [ __ ] what are you
gonna do about that your wife
is dead you killed her ah she's a [ __ ]
i can't believe this is all you served
for thanksgiving i mean seriously we
have everything we need this
is called being safe this is
responsibility you're taking money from
george soros you paid i'm prepared to
live in this
for another three to five years you're
killing everybody your wife is dead
and your daughter is a prostitute the
economy is good my daughter's
on only fans and she's getting some real
[ __ ] traction i'm your brother
and you want me dead is this what you
want you invented chronovirus with china
to take out our leader and i can't
believe i can call you my [ __ ]
brother
you're super through your wife is dead i
can't understand
you're not understanding what i'm saying